[MUSIC PLAYING]
SIMON MARGOLIS: My
name is Simon Margolis.
I direct the Cloud Platform
practice at SADA Systems,
and SADA's had the pleasure
of working with our panelists
to help them with
their Cloud journey.
I want to go through
panel here, and just
give a quick introduction,
and ask everyone
to maybe introduce yourself and
talk a little bit about what
you do.
Without further ado, Anastasia
Zamyshlyaeva with Reltio,
please.
ANASTASIA ZAMYSHLYAEVA:
Thank you, Simon.
My name is Anastasia,
and over seven years ago
I co-founded a company
which is named Reltio.
Our goal was to
build products that
allow us to organize all
of the enterprise data
in one single place.
Let me give you an example.
Let's say I'm working in a
wealth management company,
and there is not that
many opportunities,
and finding new clients
is extremely hard.
Let's say in my system I have
a person whose name is Scott,
and he's a software engineer,
and most likely I'll
be not targeting this person.
But from other sources
from the enterprise,
I realize that there are
more details about Scott.
Scott is working in company
XYZ, and recently in the news,
we learned that it had a very
successful round of funding.
Based on all the statistics
through the enterprise,
we know that these kind of
companies are going IPO.
There are more details.
Scott actually was the first
developer in this company.
Now you see that
all this context
is giving a completely
different flavor to Scott.
Now as a person working in
a wealth management company,
I need to reach out to this
person as fast as possible,
because two years from now,
it will be already too late.
But the problem is
that in the enterprise
there is no single place
where I could get all
of this information together.
That's why at Reltio
our mission was
to build a place where I can
have reliable data from all
over the enterprise
that I can transform
into relevant insights.
I also want to have
recommendation frameworks,
so instead of scanning through
millions of profiles of Scotts,
I can have just an
alert in the system.
Hey, Stasia, you need to
work with this person.
If you think about
the enterprise,
it was an example about
wealth management.
But in every enterprise, there
are the same kind of problems.
You want to leverage
all the information
about individuals,
organizations, products,
to drive your business.
SIMON MARGOLIS:
Thank you, Stasia.
Next, Aaron Brown with MadHive.
If you could, tell us a
little bit about yourself.
AARON BROWN: Hi,
my name is Aaron.
I work at MadHive.
I'm the VP of engineering.
MadHive is a New York
based ad tech firm.
For those who
don't know, ad tech
is the science
and infrastructure
behind advertising.
It comes with a lot of
engineering challenges.
We deal with very,
very large scale.
There are real-time
exchanges for ads.
Advertisers don't
know where you're
going to go on
the internet next,
and you just appear,
and we have to make sure
that the right
advertisement gets there.
There are a whole lot more ads
on the internet than just about
anything else, so it gets big.
The data science is
also very important.
If we show you the wrong
ad, then you just pass off,
and that's money lost.
The other thing we work on
very heavily is privacy.
That's almost sort of
contradictory in that industry,
but privacy is very,
very important.
We believe privacy is a human
right, first and foremost.
Advertising is kind of creepy
in that regard-- sort of follow
you around everywhere.
You looked at that bicycle
on Amazon one time,
and it's everywhere you go.
That's sort of weird, and
even in an innocent case,
a little creepy.
The nefarious cases
are very creepy,
so we'd like to stop that.
Also, advertising has problems
because of that huge scale,
and because of all those very,
very low latency requirements,
there are tons and
tons of companies
involved in the
advertising supply chain--
maybe sometimes 20 companies
just to show you one ad.
When you have 20 companies
working on data in an industry
where data is your
value, you want
to work together
and check notes,
but you don't want to
show each other anything.
What happens is there
are very, very large
discrepancies, sometimes
to the order of 10%,
which is not great because ads
are kind of like digital money.
We're like the original
digital currency.
Each one of those little
ads is some money.
When you're being fast and
loose with people's money,
it's a big problem.
We try to solve all these
things at once with privacy.
Privacy is about securing
data to make sure
that it's not tampered with--
always in your control.
This works really
well for us consumers,
and also works really, really
well for us in the ad tech
business, because now when data
has provenance and control,
the stuff like doing
accounting, auditing,
gets really, really easy.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Awesome.
Thank you, Aaron.
Josh Gray, principal architect
with Citrix, if you could,
tell us a little
bit about yourself.
JOSH GRAY: All right.
Thanks, Simon.
I actually just joined
Citrix a few months ago
when they acquired my last
company, called Cedexis.
What we did at Cedexis is,
for about the last nine years,
we built the largest community
of global internet performance
data in the world.
We started about 2009,
and grew it to a place
where we see about a
billion users every day.
We collect tens of
billions of data points,
and we aggregate that all to
give insight into what's really
going on in the internet.
We effectively measure
every major public provider
of infrastructure, many private
providers of infrastructure.
We watch whether
there's congestion,
how the throughput is
behaving, what the round trip
times look like.
We roll all that data
through a very rich analytics
and reporting
infrastructure, and we also
do a very active, very
low latency global traffic
management based on that.
There's a lot of very high
skill, very high speed,
very low latency use
cases that we deal with.
The nature of the
business that we're in
is that we are
actually consumers
of virtually all of these
providers that we monitor.
We keep an eye on
them, but we also
run a 24/7, 365, global
service on top of them.
And Google has been our
fastest growing vendor
that we use as it's continued
to capture use cases
in our own infrastructure.
We continue to be
multi-cloud, multi-vendor,
and that will likely
continue, but on the merits
of what we see with the
use cases that we capture,
it's been a really
exciting journey
to keep moving things forward.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Awesome.
Thank you, Josh.
Then, last, we'll go to Glen
Pringle, innovation lead
at Monash University.
GLEN PRINGLE: Thanks, Simon.
Monash University is the
largest university in Australia.
Although we're
only 60 years old,
we've got presence
across four continents,
and we're the number
one university
for engineering and technology
in Australia, as well.
Being such a large
university, we've
got a really diverse
set of needs.
We have numerous researchers.
We're a research-intensive
university.
They have enormous
different needs.
We have educators.
We have a very large
number of students.
We've actually found
that we are using Cloud
more and more so
that they can meet
a lot of those diverse needs.
So as an innovation lead, I'm
working with those people,
and looking to really help
them to make use of Cloud,
and in particular Google
Cloud, to achieve that.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Thank you, Glen.
I'll actually start
with you, since you're
holding the microphone.
I wanted to ask you a little
bit about what really drove you
to start adopting the Cloud.
Then, if you could,
talk a little bit
about why Google Cloud in
particular stood out to you.
GLEN PRINGLE: Sure.
We didn't actually approach
Cloud looking to reduce cost.
We were looking for
a number of things.
We were really looking
for flexibility.
As we're trying to achieve those
things I mentioned earlier,
we're wanting solutions where
we can quickly and easily
be able to use the resources--
and looking for a real
range of different resources
to do a lot of different things.
Speed of delivery is a
really big thing, too.
Previously, if we were
working with infrastructure,
it took a lot of
time to prepare,
to get that
infrastructure ready,
to bring it into production.
Whereas, when we're
going with Cloud,
it's available when we need it.
It's not just being able
to bring it in instantly,
it's also about
being able to use
that really wide range
of different resources,
and bring them in
as we need them.
Scalability-- as I
already mentioned,
being able to ramp up
with infrastructure.
When we used to
run into problems,
we would have to go
and order new hardware.
If we wanted to scale up, there
would be up to months' time
before that became available.
Whereas, once
we're in the Cloud,
we now see that using auto
scaling, that hardware, that
compute is available before
we even know that we need it.
As we look at the issues
around people, process,
and technology, we've actually
found that using Cloud
takes technology out of that.
It becomes the simplest
part of those three.
We're no longer
really struggling
to deal with that technology
side like we used to be.
SIMON MARGOLIS: That's awesome.
That's great to know.
So actually my next question,
right next to you, is for Josh.
JOSH GRAY: We didn't
plan this, really.
SIMON MARGOLIS: This
is only starting well.
We'll have to play hot
microphone in a little bit.
So you mentioned you've worked
in a few different Cloud
providers.
You work in a few different
environments overall.
What challenges are
you looking to solve
that lead you towards
looking for some alternatives
to what you already
had in your wheelhouse
and eventually to Google?
JOSH GRAY: Yes.
Our early use case that
brought us to Google Cloud
is we have really, really,
really large data sets.
Tens of billions of
rows with hundreds
of columns and attributes
that are collected constantly.
We have a lot of really low
latency cases to get insight.
Our data gets a lot less
interesting the more
time passes.
As days, weeks, hours
go by, if that's
how long it takes
to get results,
sometimes that's not
meaningful anymore.
Our main use case was to extract
more valuable information out
of our data sets and make it
more accessible to our teams.
We ended up looking through
a lot of different data
architectures, and have tried
virtually everything that
exists, and got really
attracted to BigQuery early on,
and pushed it hard.
We had many millions
of tables of data,
did some good work
with the BQ team
on refining our approaches
so that it aligned
with their expectations,
and ended up
getting some really,
really amazing results.
To me, there's a lot
of solutions out there.
There's a lot of options
for data and analytics
and that kind of approach.
But what really made
the difference is
it was truly a managed service.
You just dumped data
into it, and then you
have SQL access to it.
You don't have to think about
things like instant sizing.
There's truly a managed
layer to it that just works.
The fact that I could do
multi-terabyte inquiries
with SQL, which the
vast majority of my team
was already familiar
with, really
made it so that people started
pulling out value a lot
more easily.
There was no training, no
specialized familiarity
of a new framework,
or a new programming
model that had to be done.
That got us into BigQuery.
It has been a large part
of our infrastructure
for several years now.
We continue to
grow and push that.
We've actually been
layering in other use cases.
We do a lot of things just with
instances in global management.
We do a lot of edge computing.
The quality of engineering
resulting-- we're
in the business of
watching all these Cloud
providers and all these CDNs
and all these data centers.
We get a tremendous
amount of data,
not just through
our own collection,
but also with our customers
who help us collect this data.
Just on the merits
of a lot of these,
like the engineering of the
edge platform between the Clouds
is just really impressive work.
A lot of the capabilities
for very rapid changing
of virtualized resources--
again, really, really,
really good results.
As a result, we've
had increasing tiers
through our stack that
have gotten picked up
with the solutions that are
running on Google Cloud.
SIMON MARGOLIS: That's great.
It sounds like there were
some unique things to GCP that
allowed you to do things you
otherwise would have, I guess,
had a lot of pain around.
JOSH GRAY: It was
absolutely true.
There's one other dimension,
too, A lot of the offerings,
they were externalizations
of very mature technology--
BigQuery's based on
the Dremel paper,
which is 10-ish years old.
Not only had there been a lot
of good thinking, good work,
but the solution had
a lot of miles on it
with their own internal usage.
We've found that, frequently,
even the newer offerings,
they're new to us on the
outside, but a lot of them
have been in use
for five, 10 years,
and they have a lot
of experience baked
into both the implementation
and the design that
really makes for a really,
really solid offering.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Awesome.
Thank you for that.
The next question actually
is for you, Stasia.
It's a relatively
similar question,
which is we know you
shifted over to use
GCP for some of your workloads.
Can you explain why you chose
GCP, and what kind of workloads
you're using it for?
ANASTASIA ZAMYSHLYAEVA: Sure.
There were actually
different stages
for us moving to Google Cloud
with different mutations.
Let me cover some of
the use cases maybe
you can correlate to yours.
The first case, we were
running our platform in Amazon,
and we had a lot of APIs,
users were using UIs,
and we wanted to
understand what's
the usage of the platform,
what customers are doing,
what's the cost for
different customers.
So we collected all
of this information
in one single place.
It was Google BigQuery,
where we could
store all of this information
at very cheap cost,
and then have a querying
mechanism on top of that.
We could build the reports that
we could use internally, as
well as share with customers.
Then there is also a
very nice addition.
Google has a product
called Google Data Studio
that allows us to visualize--
it's kind of a BI tool.
It allows us to visualize
for us the reports,
and, again, share with
customers and ourselves,
understanding what is
actually happening.
This is the first use case.
It was long before when you
migrated the whole platform.
Another use case was we wanted
to build product from scratch.
We decided to go with
a relatively small team
of developers and deliver this
product as fast as possible
without any data ops.
For this we used managed
services from Google.
We used App Engine
with all the caches,
with indexes that are
there, with data store.
We were able to deliver
this product very fast.
One very nice thing, when you
roll out this kind of product,
is the cost grows as you grow.
Initially, if you don't
have usage of that product,
you're actually not
paying for this much.
When you have the
adoption, this is
when you start paying,
as well as the auto
scaling that is still there.
Right now, if you don't have
usage at the current moment,
you are not paying.
But when there are
a spike of requests,
this is when we can easily
scale up and meet the customer's
requirements.
Right now, I think the
biggest one is actually--
when we moved our platform
from Amazon to Google--
the reason for this,
the motivation here,
was we wanted to meet the
requirements for our customers
who wanted to be in
Google, and didn't want
to be in other Cloud providers.
With this, it was one
of the motivation.
Other motivations that
we heard is, frequently,
people who are migrating
to Google get better cost
efficiency.
And the reason for this
is because of the network
that you have with
Google, the pricing model,
the flexibility-- how we can
switch between the instance
types.
So it was one of
the motivations.
Another one was we wanted to mix
and match the best technologies
from different Cloud providers,
not tying to a specific Cloud
provider.
If there is a database that can
give replication across regions
and very fast response
time, we would
like to wrap it
into our product,
and give it to our customers.
Another example is
machine learning.
We want to take all of this and,
again, give to our customers,
no matter if they're residing
in one Cloud or another.
That's three use cases why
we're switching to Google Cloud.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Those
are great stories,
and, obviously, it's been great
to be a part of that journey
and see those
transformations that you've
been able to recognize, both
from a technology perspective,
as well as from a
business perspective.
Actually, Aaron, I have a
similar question for you,
which is--
I think I was
really lucky to work
with you during the assessment
process for figuring out
where you wanted to
run your new workloads.
You have some really
interesting requirements.
So I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about what
those nuanced requirements are,
and what the decision making
process was like when you were
looking for a Cloud provider.
AARON BROWN: Well, a lot
of the team at MadHive
we've plucked from other
very smart start-ups.
So we built a very
impressive team
who have experience
across all Clouds.
When you get the best
of the best together,
they say, I want to work
on Google Cloud Platform.
It's a funny story.
We actually tried to
hire Simon to do that,
and then we found out that we
don't have to pay for SADA.
We get SADA for
free with Google.
It's great.
The best of the best.
Things that were
super important to us
for rolling out
our products were
first and foremost serverless
managed everything,
and we mean that to
the absolute extreme.
Because when you have
these elite engineers,
what you don't want
them to be doing
is sitting there restarting
EC2 Instance all day.
You want to be paying
them to do what
they are absolutely amazing
at and just creating
stuff all day.
They talk about Google
Cloud as cheaper,
or like gigabytes and
gigahertz, and this and that.
Yes, that's true.
But that's thousands of dollars.
You know, when you
talk about salaries,
that's millions of dollars
saved, plus opportunities
captured.
It lets us really out-maneuver
lots of companies in the space,
and it's gotten us
very quickly here
on the stage talking what
we do, which is cool.
Thanks, Google Cloud.
A couple of things that
SADA helped us with
was in advertising.
Sometimes the workloads can
get really, really spiky--
like really spiky.
All of North America is waiting
for 8:00 PM for the show
to start.
They just wait, and
then at that one second,
there's this tsunami of
requests that comes at you.
There is no product on
any Cloud that scales
like App Engine's standard.
You can just put
it and forget it,
and that is absolutely critical
to us, because ads are money.
There's literal money.
If you drop one request,
that's lost money.
SIMON MARGOLIS: I remember
working with you early on.
We identified an area where I
think we saved-- what was it?
Maybe 100 milliseconds
of latency,
and you were so excited
about that because
of all the additional
things you could
do with those
additional milliseconds.
I love that story
because it really
speaks to what you
can do when you're
working at the scale
of what GCP provides.
AARON BROWN: Yeah, you can do
a lot of database look-ups,
machine learning work.
You can do a lot of stuff
in 100 milliseconds.
SIMON MARGOLIS: As
long as we're talking
about large scale, Josh, I
think I have a question for you,
as well.
You kind of hinted at
this in your introduction.
You process just a
tremendous amount of data,
and you need to get
insights from that data.
Can you tell us a little bit
about what, within GCP, has
helped you overcome the natural
hurdles that come from having
to achieve goals like yours?
JOSH GRAY: Scale
is always something
that we design for and
constantly are evolving
and work on significantly.
I mean our business is up
many orders of magnitude
per every few years.
Now that we are part of a
bigger family with Citrix,
we're optimistic that will keep
moving in the same direction,
probably at a faster pace.
I'm going to leave
right after the talk
to go get some work done.
But the main tools with scale--
I'll go back to,
again, the agility.
A couple of things that stand
out is the experience of GCP.
When you look at the APIs,
they're just generally
remarkably well done, and easy
to understand and consistent.
That leads to velocity
with how quickly
people can write systems and
interact with them that take
advantage of the capabilities.
That is not always
a true experience
across different providers,
where the inconsistency ends up
burning time as you figure
things out and get them dialed.
The services themselves--
velocity and reactivity,
you can feel, whether it's
App Engine's ability to scale,
or the load balancer's
ability to scale,
or the ability to hot
migrate instances.
There's just this
underlying design ethos
that your platform is at least
as fast as you want to go,
and that's always
good, because you
know you're the limiting
factor in your design.
You're not you're not
banking on infrastructure
that is going to
put a limit on it
that you may not
even know about.
It may not even be
in the documentation.
That's always a really
important aspect.
That, in particular, is what
has pushed some of our use cases
beyond even BigQuery out
into moving on to running
on Google's Platform.
How they approached edge--
we're all about speed.
We run out of about 100
different points on the planet,
because we do, among other
things, global DNS services,
and that's where 10 or
20 milliseconds is a lot.
You don't want to take that.
You don't want to spend that
in transit time for somebody
to be able to get
an answer for you.
And being able to take advantage
of the breadth of the data
centers, and the
data center growth,
and the commitment to expansion,
and in the architecture
of that edge--
where they any cast external
IPs and have some capabilities
to bring your resources for
fulfillment closer to where
the requests originate.
Those are all really,
really important features,
and things that have earned
the respect of our team
as they explore and
develop and grow
on those kinds of capabilities.
SIMON MARGOLIS: I
think it's worth
mentioning-- you mentioned the
acquisition, but prior to that,
you were really doing a lot of
this with a very small team.
I imagine there's a
lot of what GCP offers
that facilitated that, right?
JOSH GRAY: Yeah, we
had 20-some engineers,
and we deliver many billions
of mission critical decisions,
and collect many
tens of billions
of data points every day
for companies like LinkedIn
and Pinterest and Airbnb.
We're running as part of
the plumbing that delivers
all of those sites to you.
Again, we do that with
20-some engineers.
A lot of that's about
choosing very carefully.
I talked about the
efficiency of the APIs,
and the efficiency
of the tooling,
and taking advantage of
the right-managed tiers
for the right services.
You're not always
running raw instances.
We do some of that for
our highly custom stuff,
but you're also taking advantage
of things like BigQuery
for manage--
I don't have to worry
about managing a data pool,
and I don't have to worry
about deciding on my sharding
and scaling.
I just dump data in, and
put SQL against it, and out
of the chute with no more
investment than that,
I get pretty darned
good results.
I can actually even
then grow from there
to get into some more
specialized use cases.
It's like Aaron mentioned,
too, that you want your people
spending their time on
the most important part
of your solution.
You don't want them spending
their time on the parts
that somebody else, frankly,
can do better than you.
The implicit part of
that I want to talk about
is you're also, by
extension, taking
those people who run the managed
services as part of your team.
If they mess up their service,
that results in your service
not being of the quality
that you want to do.
Which products you
choose, and the quality
of the product they've built,
and the quality of the team
that runs it, is important.
Across a variety of providers
and a variety of products,
I think we've all seen that that
isn't always a super high bar.
So choosing carefully
is an important part
to maintaining team
velocity and scaling,
so that 20 people
can run something
that runs mission critical
services for so many companies
around the globe.
SIMON MARGOLIS: That's
a great perspective.
Continuing this theme
of massive scale, Glen,
I would like to turn
to you, as well.
I think we've had the unique
privilege of working together
on two distinct projects,
a massive G Suite
project, and then a similarly
massive GCP implementation.
Being that Monash is one of the
largest universities in terms
of G Suite users, certainly the
largest university in Australia
in terms of students,
can you tell me
a little bit about
what synergies
you found between
G Suite and GCP,
especially on the scale
you're operating on?
GLEN PRINGLE: We initially
went with G Suite back in 2009.
At that point in time, we
were one of the largest
organizations-- well, definitely
the largest university
in Australia going
with G Suite--
one of the largest in the world.
We rolled that out over a couple
of years, and since that time,
we've seen a constant growth
in the use of G Suite.
Right now, we've got
about 120,000 active users
within G Suite,
and we've continued
to see a lot of increase in
the use of the various apps.
As we have pretty much every
active student and staff
member using it, it's a
very natural progression
for a lot of those users who
want to do a little bit more
to be able to move
in to using GCP.
There is no effort for them
to actually begin using GCP.
With other systems, they often
have to go and get access
given to them.
They need to be given
to the resources.
Whereas because they're
Google users through G Suite,
they can then just
begin using GCP.
It's been interesting watching
over the last couple of years,
especially, how a
lot of our students
are beginning to try a
lot of different things.
They're developing projects
on their own, in some cases.
Our researchers can
very easily get access
to resources that
otherwise have to go
through all sorts
of other mechanisms
to get those resources.
Just the fact that
they're Google users
every single day makes
it really, really
easy to make that transition.
SIMON MARGOLIS: That's great.
The things you were able
to talk about where you're
able to enable your students
to do really impressive work,
I think is a great story that
is, I think, unique to Monash.
That's very cool to see.
Stasia, I think, back to you.
See?
I didn't plan this
all that well.
We, again, got to work together
on your migration to GCP.
While I'd love to stand
up here and say everything
went fantastically and
we hit no roadblocks,
certainly that's not the case,
as you find in large scale
migration projects.
Could you tell us
a little about what
hurdles you ran into
during your shift to GCP,
and what you did
to overcome them?
ANASTASIA ZAMYSHLYAEVA:
Actually, there
were not that many problems
during the migration.
We had really great support from
our Google team, and from SADA,
with a lot of experience
doing these kinds of projects.
Actually, there were
not that many things
that we had challenges with.
Also, the thing that we were
migrating from AWS to GCP,
the architecture itself it
was designed multi-cloud.
It wasn't relying on any of the
managed services from Amazon,
and that's why it was just
rewriting some of the Terraform
scripts, and running the
same kind of workload,
but on Google Cloud.
The whole project from
the beginning, when
we were making the design--
how it will be
working in Google--
through the testing,
as well as data
migration for some of the
customers, took two months.
After two months,
we already were
having the first customer
who was leveraging
our platform in Google Cloud.
I would say that,
if at that point,
we were using Kubernetes,
then this whole migration
could take much
shorter time frame.
There were some lessons
learned, though,
especially on the pricing side.
Something that you
need to think about--
typically, a Serisys
would be breaking down
into two categories.
The first one is stateless,
another stateful.
So with a stateless, it is
critical to use the oldest
scaling.
Certainly, you can go
with the alternative
with using App Engine, but we
wanted to have more control,
and have faster migration
to Google Cloud.
In this case, think
of your scalability.
If you want to have the cost
efficiency for the baseline
capacity, its better to go
with committed use notes,
and then you will have
the discount for those.
But for the older
scale part, which
is typically 80% of your
cluster, go with preemptibles.
The benefits of this-- you
will have the bigger discount,
you will have better cost model.
But those notes could
be taken at any time.
But for older scale,
it should be fine.
For the stateful, if
you have an ability
to switch to managed service,
this will be the best.
First of all, the
older scale is there
that, typically, you will
not get from a database
that you are managing, as
well as the cost, because
of the multi-tenancy that
Google already takes care of.
If you have to
manage your database,
then go and buy
all the instances
as committed use notes,
because typically databases
are not scaling down.
These are the main
lessons that we
learned that were
different from Amazon.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Absolutely.
It seems to be a
recurring theme,
where there is this need
amongst many of our customers
to look at--
I mean, as we all see
from this conference,
there's a lot of
stuff that Google's
doing-- some really, really
cool, powerful things that
are sort of new to the market.
This is something we see
regularly is the need
to look at all of
these offerings
and figure out what are the
best tools for your use cases.
Actually, Aaron,
the next question
would be for you on
that same thread,
because you're using
a lot of App Engine,
you're using a lot of Bigtable.
These are things that are
somewhat unique to Google.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
makes those advantages
for your business
versus your competition?
AARON BROWN: Yeah, that's easy.
These are the things that
scale absolutely infinitely.
Bigtable was my first look into
the potential here for Google
as a platform for advertising.
When we were just us getting our
feet wet, running some queries,
and getting results back
as fast as the network
card on my machine in
their office could go,
I knew we were on to something.
Since then, it's only been
more and more and more--
out of the box, it's phenomenal.
When you add on more
layers, you know
that that great
engineering team has
made it do incredible magic.
I can't imagine doing
advertising at the scale
that MadHive does running
a bunch of sharded MySQL
and engine acts,
and stuff like that.
It just wouldn't happen.
Surprise!
Google knows a thing
about advertising.
SADA has helped us stay very
Google-y inside of MadHive.
It's a great resource for us.
SIMON MARGOLIS:
Like you said, you
have a small team of
really bright people.
You don't waste their
time managing the stuff
they don't have to manage.
AARON BROWN: No, they have
enough work to do already.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Actually, Glen,
my next question is for you.
Monash University has
a lot going on, right?
It's a massive university.
Can you tell us a
little bit about what
you're seeing, in
terms of the ability
to better innovate across
the campus by leveraging ECP?
GLEN PRINGLE: Sure.
As a couple of people
already mentioned,
Google App Engine provides
a lot of opportunity.
We almost exclusively
use that aspect of GCP,
and it provides
us the opportunity
to both cheaply and easily put
into place customized solutions
to different problems.
As a couple of examples
of the sorts of things
that we're seeing, we recently
had the campus security group
approach us.
They had an issue
that they wanted
to be able to try to track
the shuttle buses that
run around campus.
In the lead-up to
the exam period,
they wanted the students
to be able to find
when that bus was
going to arrive,
so that they could
know where to head for,
and when to get there
to get to their exam.
The previous solution that
they had had fallen apart.
We had almost no time
to develop this in.
Within five days
we were able to--
with one dev, one engineer--
put together a solution.
We used IoT devices
on those buses,
and from there we
imported the data.
We used Google App Engine,
Firebase, and also Google Maps.
We had a solution
up, from very start
of the request coming in
to the working solution,
within five days.
That's the sort of thing
that is just about impossible
to achieve using other methods.
In terms of quick and
easy, pulling together
the different components, that
worked really well for us.
Now, another other problem--
and this is a different scale.
The Institute of
Railway Technology
is a group within
our university who
deal with a lot of
issues on railroads,
and they have a lot of
monitoring analytics
and those sorts of things.
They work with
mining trains that
run in the Outback
of Australia--
some of the harshest conditions
you can get on the planet.
One of the interesting
things, they
put tracking equipment
on those trains.
I was talking to Simon
about this the other night.
If something goes wrong
with these devices,
it can be up to two years
before they can get access
to be able to replace them.
So when you talk about downtime
if something goes wrong,
it's rare that you get more
than a couple of years downtime.
They've got to be sure that
everything works really well.
These IoT devices are
tracking a whole range
of different things.
They're tracking things like
vibrations, sound, location,
all sorts of different things.
The idea is that they want
to be able to understand
where sections of track
actually need maintenance.
That data is being fed
back to Google, where
we can do analytics on it.
There's a whole range
of different components
that we can pull together
from GCP to actually do that.
One of the most exciting
areas that I'm actually
finding with that is in the
whole ML space and things
like autoML Vision
and other things that
are providing enormous
opportunities to actually
enhance what we can
do in this area.
SIMON MARGOLIS: Yes, I think
we're hearing a theme here,
where you're able to do a
whole lot more with a whole lot
less, in terms of human
resources, in terms of time
to deployment, even in terms
of scale in the case by RT.
It's really interesting.
On that same vein,
Josh, I know when
we started working
together, you were
dealing with a relatively
speaking much smaller deal
of data than you are today.
Can you talk a little bit
about what, if anything,
really had to change
in order to accommodate
the significant increase in
volume that you encounter
today?
JOSH GRAY: Yes.
We've been on a
classic startup path.
You start with one,
and you're super
excited about your first
customer that brings you
a little bit of traffic.
Then you just you grow
and grow and grow.
Now we're part of
the Citrix family,
and Citrix is all
about choice and Cloud
and optimizing and mobilizing
delivery of data and apps.
We're really excited about
playing a significant role
in that.
Our architecture and our product
has evolved several times
as we've gotten
larger, and as we've
taken on more and more vendors.
On day one, we operated--
I think we might have had
a little bit of Amazon,
but we did a lot of
lease Dyer and CoLOS
and leased
infrastructure from CDNs,
and there was a lot of
interesting early architecture.
A lot of the ways
that we've evolved
that to deal with
scale, again, was
to continue to leverage the
fact that our system is very
layered, and has a
lot of microservices,
and has a lot of
internal decomposition
so that we can move
those things forward.
The nice side
effect of that is we
can move entire tiers of
our internal operations
in how they operate, what
technologies they use,
what vendors they use, and we do
that all while running a 24/7,
365, zero downtime operation.
We don't get to say,
I'm sorry, we're not
going to resolve DNS names
for the next two hours,
because we need to do
some work on the system.
Any given second of
every single day,
we will get hundreds of
thousands of requests,
sometimes many more.
As Aaron was talking about,
a lot of our customers
deal with news and media
and things like that,
so sometimes you
will get spikes.
We do a lot of work
with game delivery.
Christmas morning is a
remarkable time for us,
as well, because everybody is
opening up their game consoles
and downloading updates
to all of their games.
You get this incredibly spiky,
sometimes very unpredictable--
I mean, you can
predict it's going
to happen on Christmas
morning, but you never quite
know how large it's going to
be, or exactly when it'll hit,
or things like that.
So you need to keep leveraging
that the layers in your system
can be as reactive and adaptive
and resilient and everything,
and that's been a
key as we've evolved.
It's a big reason why
we've taken on the layers
that we've taken on-- that
we've moved into Google Cloud--
because they delivered
uniquely reactive, uniquely
resilient capabilities
that we leverage.
Sometimes it really
matters in the details.
A lot of people talk about
auto this or auto that,
but when you actually peel
the onion a little bit
and do some testing,
well, it's sort of auto,
and it's sort of
fast, and it might
take a few minutes
or a few hours,
or you might hit a hard limit on
the resources in a data center.
Those things are all
really important,
because at the end of the
day, our customers don't care.
We either deliver the
service or we don't.
The latter is really
not an option for us,
so we choose our vendors wisely.
We choose our
technologies wisely,
and we've been continuing
to evolve that.
The one last point is being
part of the Citrix family
has been really exciting,
because we're leveraging
a lot of our best practices
across some of the other Cloud
offerings, and desktop
delivery offerings, and Cloud
utilization scenarios.
We're looking
forward to bringing
a lot of that same kind
of mentality and approach
to the broader offerings
and the good work
that they're already doing
in a lot of those spaces.
SIMON MARGOLIS: It's
an awesome insight
that you're able to
provide, because I
think your team generally has
stayed pretty similar in size.
Echoing what the other
panelists have said,
you've really been
able to do so much
more by leveraging
various components of what
Cloud has to offer.
I think it's a great story.
So, Aaron, I have
another one for you,
just because this is one of my
favorite things to talk about.
We joke all the time that
you deal with Blockchain,
and you deal with
Cloud computing.
Are there any other
buzzwords that I'm missing?
AARON BROWN: AI.
SIMON MARGOLIS: These
sound like I'm just
trying to sell a white
paper or something by saying
blockchaining and Cloud
computing in the same sentence,
but it's what
you're really doing.
Can you tell us a little bit
about what those things do
together, and how you're
able to achieve what you
do using those technologies?
AARON BROWN: This is
a really good question
that we get a lot, because
it's not a secret that we're
very big users of Google Cloud.
We're also very active in
the Blockchain community.
Our researchers dedicate
tons of time to it.
We have a lot of contributions
that we're super proud of.
But people who are familiar
with Blockchain are like, hey,
this is literally
a Cloud competitor.
The Cloud is all about
centralization and authority,
and Blockchain is all
about decentralization,
and not having to trust--
knowing things are true
through cryptography.
They actually work really,
really well together.
So if you recall, we talked
about in the beginning
about one of the big problems
in advertising is auditing.
Ads are literally money.
The auditing
standards should even
be higher because
this is a case where,
unlike banking on Wall
Street where there
are shares and dollars
and things that go around,
ads get made.
You just create money.
If you have opportunity
to create money,
and you have a lot of
opacity in the supply chain,
there's going to be problems.
One of the things
that we do is--
I'm going to walk back
through this whole process.
You can use cryptography.
Cryptography is more than
just encrypting messages.
Cryptography is
about also validating
the integrity of data, without
necessarily revealing why.
For example, if we
have REST Endpoints,
most REST Endpoints are
like, there's a web request,
it does a database query, and
then it gives back a result.
With the addition of
cryptography on this,
we can make it that the data--
even though you didn't reveal
what happened underneath--
we can reveal the provenance
and the supply
chain of that data.
Then that's super
useful, because now it's
just as easy as a REST
Endpoint, but now I get to know,
OK, this data has some validity.
It went through partners, and
it went through transforms,
and I don't have to know
exactly what those transforms
were to know that it's correct.
Because if even
one thing changed,
everything just breaks.
Cryptography is neat like that.
The other thing we can do is
you want some universal base.
We have this string,
almost, that carries
through all the data as it
goes through the supply chain.
That's where the Blockchain
part really comes in.
It becomes really
useful, because that
is our universal truth where
everyone in the industry
is working really, really
hard to maintain this
to some base level of truth.
The math gets
complicated, but just
say we're all agreeing
that the number is five.
The number is five
right now, and that's
where I'll anchor our strings.
Now across the entire
ecosystem, we're
doing REST calls, database
lookups, queries, transforms,
behind people servers
in large data centers.
But we know with absolute
cryptographic certainty
that the answers are correct.
Also, when we're done sharing
data we can revoke that.
Immediately, it goes all the
way through the supply chain,
not by trust, not
by contracts, not
even by privacy laws like
the new European regulation
of privacy, GDPR--
literally by the
force of physics.
Cryptography.
That's a really, really
exciting solution
to be able to offer
in our industry,
and we've been working with
the Blockchain standards
body for advertising,
called AdLedger.
We're also one of the founders,
along with IBM and Techna
and a bunch of large companies.
So we're happy to make
that contribution.
But I think the most exciting
thing about that combination
is--
you talked about
Cloud and Blockchain--
I've been attending
a lot of the sessions
here about machine learning.
Google and Cloud is all about
AI and machine learning.
That is the killer use case.
But machine learning and AI
are only as good as the data
that you can source.
While Google has done an
amazing job of collecting up
tons and tons of
data in one place--
and it shows in their
products-- there
is a limit to that,
because we can't all
share our business data or, as
consumers, our private data.
We probably don't even want that
to go into these big machine
learning things.
That is a hard stop for
the evolution of AI.
It shouldn't have
to be like that.
We can use the same
privacy techniques
that we discussed for
consumers and across these data
supply chains, and you can put
that into machine learning.
That's the killer app.
AI plus cryptography
is everything.
That's literally
the new internet.
I think that's what
we're going to be talking
about here in the next decade.
SIMON MARGOLIS: No,
I love that story
because I think that is
the common misconception
is that these are somehow
competing technologies.
But you really do
paint the picture
as to how these things can
actually be very complimentary.
I love squashing
that bad stereotype.
Unfortunately, I think we're
just about out of time here.
I just wanted to thank all of
you for being here with us.
Thank you all for
attending, and we will all
be somewhere around
here afterwards
if anyone has any
questions for us.
Thank you, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]